[Music]
you have to do the verb to be the noun
that's it intuition that's the most
valuable tool that you have that's the
most important compass in our lives the
only way you can win in this world and
most importantly in this life is to be
unapologetically you creativity is a
habit it's not a skill so welcome
everybody to the mom of the Masters show
the goal of this show is to bring on
people who I respect and I want to learn
from and pick their brains and hopefully
in that process you guys learn as well
coming on today is a long-term friend of
the channel mister Chase Jarvis this guy
has an awesome company called creative
life and he's got a new book coming out
what is a job it's when it when is it
out if you buy it now it'll be at your
house on Tuesday so it's coming out like
ASAP creative calling III took I took
the jacket off of mine just to protect
it cuz I'm travelling right now
chase man welcome aboard thank you so
much man I appreciate it
love you in the community and decided to
be on the show this morning
awesome so I've been working my way
through this I'm a slow reader
I put down the other book I was working
through because I wanted to I wanted to
dive through this well first off I love
the premise so the premise is everybody
is creative yep for so many people who
say I'm not creative I'm just not the
creative type you're basically saying
that's BS you're creative too you just
have to tap into it yeah I'm saying
three things one that every person is
creative - not only is every person
creative but creativity is a muscle
creativity is a habit it's not a skill
and it's like it's like Maya Angelou
said creativity is an infinite resource
the more you use the more you have so if
you think of creativity as a muscle and
you you employ it in small business like
think three is and if you use creativity
in your life in small daily ways whether
you're writing code or baking a cake or
building a family or building a business
that it's in using it every day that you
realize that you actually have agency to
create your life and to me those are
three things that is the people in your
channel you do such a good job of
highlighting folks you do amazing work
and
and I think there's this gap between
most of the people who are aspiring or
starting out and what they see on TV or
in their Instagram feeds or the people
that they aspire to to learn from and be
like is that those lives weren't just
discovered those lives were created and
if you deconstruct those lives and you
sit down and talk with those people as I
have for the last ten years you realize
that it was very intentional and they
created their life just in the same way
that you would create a business or
create a meal for your family it's just
creativity in a different scale I love
it now are you in your home right now I
am in the Ace Hotel in New York I love
it oh you're in the Army New York two
men yeah I got here last night at 2:15
a.m. and I'm on a four o'clock flight
out of here so I just have a couple of
meetings and that got it yeah we should
have done that we could have done this
actually live in person that's crazy I
wish they would have next time we knew
that we got to have our schedule sync
okay so listen most of most people when
they think creative I think would think
of like the artwork behind me right
where it's like an artist a painter or
musician but what you're saying is know
what coding is creative being an
entrepreneur is being creative
how can people tap into that I mean
maybe it's first the definition of what
creativity is sure well we were sold to
live that creativity like back in
elementary school is popsicle sticks and
pipe cleaners and painting and whatnot
and this book has I have no desire to
have you go start painting or wear a
beret or move to Paris or get a
different set of friends that's not at
all what I'm talking about I'm talking
about that every person you create you
make decisions every day and when you're
deciding your life you're literally
creating we're co-creating this
experience right here you and me you're
contributing I'm contributing and we're
making something together ideally that's
beautiful and useful so those that's the
way that I think of creativity is
anytime you're combining two things to
make something new that's creativity so
if if we can expand the definition of
creativity it does a couple things that
for the people who already identify as
creative they're like yes this is my
tribe you understand me and for the
people who are like huh I've always been
creative curious or or told that I
wasn't creative this hopefully is an
empowering sort of battlecry that says
wait a minute I don't have to be a cork
in the tie
I don't have to you know life is not
happening to me life is happening for me
and when I start to put my intuition
into action which is part of the thing
that we're told oh man if you're gonna
go B you're gonna go be an entrepreneur
or that's so risky I'm here to tell you
that what's way riskier is doing what
everybody else tells you you should do
your parents your career counselor your
boss even your your spouse your peers
your parents like they tell you the
things that they tell you what you
should be for a good reason they want
you to be safe then they don't want you
to be hurt and they don't want you to
take risks but the reality is there's
nothing more risky than trying to be
somebody else the only way you can win
in this world and most importantly in
this life is to be unapologetically you
and that's like that is the key to again
all the people that you look right and
say wow I wonder how they're doing it
those answers were inside and they look
to themselves and said wait a minute
if I could write my own script take all
the constraints away and the even the
constraints like I have two kids I got a
mortgage it's number it's not practical
for me to look at just suspend that just
for a second and if you can decide what
it is you could be in this world either
a person or like what you want to do
with your career your life your
spirituality you can create that and in
fact that is what every person you
admire has done and I'm just giving you
a formula to do it so I'm curious why
you care so much I mean everybody's on a
mission everybody's on a purpose you and
creativity even going back to when you
were a successful photographer and then
we're sharing all your secrets to the
public and the people in the industry
got really you know upset at you you're
like stop spilling the secrets yeah
because you wanted to inspire other
photographers as hey like you can
achieve this too it doesn't have to be
so magical behind the scenes and then
you launch creative live with all this
great training to help people be more
creative and now I now you know creative
Colleen yeah why is it so important to
you that people find their creativity
well I'd tell you my I think a lot of
what motivates everyone of us stems from
our own personal experiences in life and
I was told early on that I'm just
telling my second grade teacher miss
Kelly I
overheard her at the ice cream social
tell my mom that I was way better at
sports than I was at art right and you
know this is 8 year old me and I just
finished making my first film I had a
comic strip going I had a stand-up
comedy routine like and and when I hear
this from a second grade teacher it
didn't crush my spirit so much as you'd
think it would but but we're social
animals we just want to fit in so I did
what miss Kelly suggested and I
basically turned my back on creativity
and ran for sports and it served me well
I was great I went to college on a
soccer scholarship played on the Olympic
Development team but I had denied my
creativity for years and started to feel
really awkward and uncomfortable I
didn't know why everything looked good
from the outside but I just felt sort of
sick and disconnected from who I really
was and then in when I was 22 my
grandfather dropped dead of a heart
attack the week before my college
graduation and it was horrible but the
silver lining was I got his canvas and
in that moment he gave me his cameras as
you know basically as he had just passed
away and all of that life that I had
ignored came rushing back to me and
ultimately it was my experimentation and
my leaning into who I really was inside
that set me free so and when I did that
my life went from happening to me to
happening for me everything started to
like I suddenly had an energy that I
didn't have before a vitality and it was
just because I had always been curious
about specifically photography and I'm
not being prescriptive about photography
we all have something in our past or we
all have something we want to be doing
right now that we're not doing and I'm
employing you to pay attention to that
your intuition that's the most valuable
tool that you have that's the most
important compass in our lives
and we've been taught to ignore it just
as I was so the reason I'm passionate
about it is because my pursuing the
dreams that everybody else had for me
cost me $100,000 in student that got me
10 years off track I went towards
medical school and professional soccer
and all these other things and when I
finally in a moment of trauma just
realized like you know what this is
really what I want to do with my life
and my life just completely transformed
in the blink of an eye and what I've
learned in my own experience
talking to people like Sir Richard
Branson and Bernie brown and and Tim
Ferriss and Arianna Huffington the
people that you you feature on your show
everybody has this experience of when
they decided to actually do the thing
they're supposed to be doing life just
transformed and so I want to give that
gift to everyone because we've all got
that thing inside of us if you had to
pick let's say a hundred great two
teachers who are then gonna use this
book as a test as a trial for a semester
in school that this is gonna be the
Field Manual for them to then give
exercise I mean this is probably it's a
pretty easy read I don't know yeah seven
year olds would be reading through it
yet but if if the book is gonna be used
as a field manuals an experiment for one
semester how would you have the great
two teachers what would you have them do
with the book what exercise would you
give them
well first it's interesting that you say
that because just yesterday on the NBC
affiliate in Seattle I launched a
program to put a book put a creative
calling book in the in the hands of
every single Seattle public school
teacher there's three Thurs mm I'm sorry
3192 teachers and so if you'd like to
you know I encourage you to buy a book
for yourself but if you go to creative
calling com
there's the ability to donate one book
ten books a hundred books anything that
you're interested in because I'm gonna
I'm gonna do this experiment that you
just talked about
Fatima's do it in real time in Seattle
and we're gonna watch the needle move
so that's Coleman if moving but if
giving back is something that speaks to
you just go to creative calling comm and
scroll down so that that's thing one
thing to I'm I'm aspiring to empower
teachers rather than the 7 year olds
specifically because they touch so many
children and I believe that creativity
is one of the things that used to be
thought to be a nice-to-have right
there's like oh cool art is cute and and
pursuing creativity is it's nice and
playful but what we know now is the
world's most successful entrepreneurs
creativity is their secret weapon the
most successful companies creativity is
the thing they invest in and this word
innovation that's just creativity
applied so what we see is
creativity is all around us literally
everything in this room that the
furniture the art on the wall is the bed
everything was created it was designed
and created so rather than think of
creativity in this sort of abstract
painting and drawing creativity is the
ability to put your manifest your ideas
in the world and I want to empower
teachers so that they can get out of
that limited mindset and start to affect
every student each each teacher has
between thirty and a hundred and fifty
students that they see every day and how
important and transformative could that
be if we empowered the teacher so what
do they do then so they read the book I
mean there's exercises in there you can
identify you've got you know different
personality types and all that stuff how
do they then translate the message to
then help a great teacher like Gracie
chase sir great tools
I would encourage to create great to
chase to keep creating his comic strip I
would give him a vehicle to publish that
comic strip
I would encourage kids to basically we
all have these things if just walk into
any second-grade classroom and say who
wants to come to the front of the room
and draw me a picture every single hand
goes up 100% unequipped everyone's like
me me me and that is that is a great
litmus test that we are all creative and
then if you ask that same question in
eighth grade half as many hands and
again as a senior half as many hands
again so that's that's evidence that the
system trains it out of us so what I
would prescribe is that we actually lean
into empowering our kids to pursue the
things that they love I mean that is the
bet is if you ask any great entrepreneur
how they became successful it's because
they found something they were
passionate about they found a problem a
challenge to to best a challenge to
overcome a product that didn't exist in
the world that they could create in
order to solve something that was near
and dear to their heart what you don't
find if you ask the most successful
entrepreneurs is like hmm I saw a an
opportunity in the marketplace
nonetheless that you have to go after
something that's personal and to mean
that personality that thing that's
inside of us that's what we teach those
second graders not to pay attention to
that and I'm saying no what do you love
let's give that to the kids and the same
thing is the parent and the same thing
just culturally we
a prescription everybody wants a map
right we want to start here follow the
dots and then end up at the red X that's
what school looks like that's what the
for the previous 40 years I've put
employment look like you go to this
college you take these classes you get
these grades and then you have this job
and then you work there for 40 years to
get the gold watch and then you're done
that's a map maps are broken they don't
exist if they ever did theirs they're
long gone all we have is a compass and
tells us which direction to walk that's
our calling and we're told to ignore
that I want everybody to start listening
to that and then walking towards it and
that's what we should be doing to our
second graders and beyond every like not
just the second graders that's the best
the basis of your question but right now
there's someone listening sitting in
their underwear in Ohio's like oh cool
Evans live I want to go check out Evan
and and there's a gap between what you
are doing right now with your life and
what you want to be doing and you told
yourself a bunch of stories about why
it's hard or why this or why that my
book is going to help you understand
that that's just a story and give you a
set of building blocks and a so steps
that you can actually get there here's
the last thing I'll say on that question
you might be far away from nothing you
might be 10,000 hours of work you might
be a couple years away it might seem far
but I tell you what you are one or two
decisions away from that life and that
is incredibly empowering you might be
five years but your two decisions the
decision to do something and then what
you do and that is incredibly empowering
to them so you talk about it being a
muscle and shadow to Ohio muscle I mean
for a lot of people it's a weak muscle
they can't they can't lift five pounds
yet but they're working towards it so
the work of muscles got to be a
consistent practice yeah what do you
recommend for somebody to make
creativity a consistent daily practice
first and foremost it's just awareness
that what you're doing is creating
something it's a really simple idea it's
just it's sort of like the first step in
mindfulness is just awareness right and
that's what meditation is it's a way
it's like you just decide to focus on
your breath or the mantra or whatever
and in this practice what I'm suggesting
is that just become aware that when
you're preparing a meal for your family
even if you're just slopping it together
you've done the same thing you same
spaghetti sauce you've been making for
twenty years what did you change it up
just a little bit double the basil add a
little more salt made it with with pork
instead of turkey or beef instead of
whatever you used to make it with and
when you do that and you do it with love
and attention and you said it in front
of someone they say how cool that this
is cool this is different I like I
appreciate that that was an act of
creativity when you're writing code
don't think of this as I'm just doing
something for my boss this is an
opportunity for me to put my my wisdom
into a piece of thing that will live on
and impact people I'm creating so the
first step is the awareness and then
once you become aware you start to look
around you say wait a minute like almost
everything that I'm doing I don't have
to walk to work the same way I can take
you know 2 2 or 3 block change in path
and I feel like I've just created a
different experience for myself and the
same is true with that job that you want
if you're at Microsoft right now and
you're an engineer or a project manager
and you want to own a cafe you do not
have to stop everything go take out a
big lease rent a bunch of equipment and
hire a bunch of people you should start
baking scones for your family on Sunday
morning then you should start having
some friends over and then you should
get into coffee and try and make the
best pour over coffee and then when you
uncover these things in small small
tangible bits every day you start to
realize hey I either love this or I
don't what I emphasize in the book and
you probably just get into this right
now because I haven't wracking your
reading skills here you're right I think
60 or something you're in the fourth
third fourth chapter is action over
intellect we all want to think our way
out of this right we want to say okay
maybe I can do this or no no just take a
step start before you're ready I think
back to some other interviews you've
done where you talked about you have a
daily routine and you have these 11 or
12 things that you want to check off
every day I don't know if you're still
doing that or not so cold shower right
is that that one of them cold shower
every day that's one of them yep so
would you recommend putting be creative
on that list for people it's on my list
I've been tracking it for six years I
create something with intention every
day even if it's just a simple photo I
don't like to be in the middle of the
stress day and I just go out find a way
to take three or four pictures with
intention I'll wake up early this
morning I woke up early and wrote in my
journal not a lot because I'm super busy
right now I'm in the middle of a book
launch but I wrote down half a dozen
things that I'm feeling something that I
want to change and something that's
going great something I'm really
grateful for and it's so powerful yet so
simple because I think that's the thing
I mean you can want to go to the gym but
if you don't schedule in the gym time
you're not gonna go to the gym people
might be listening to this watching this
so they watch the replay on YouTube and
they say bye it's amazing you'll create
but then they wake up tomorrow and they
forget the Krait cuz they haven't built
the habit yet right and and remember
habits I've got this thing that I call
the creative pyramid at the bottom is
mindset you have to believe that you can
affect your outcome you have to
understand what creativity is and
realize that you have agency over your
life that's the mindset the next step is
a set of habits right and the habits you
do these habits such that if you do them
every day you're going to accomplish
your goals which is the tip of the
pyramid right the the Egyptians knew
that if you didn't have a base of the
pyramid your pyramids not gonna exist
that's that mindset your habits that's
the gap between the mindset and the goal
it's what you do every day what you do
you become you have to do the verb to be
the noun and that's it you have to do
the verb to become the noun
I like that I haven't heard that before
is that racism Colby is that yours by a
man that's bits everywhere it's I mean
that's I think yes you have to do the
verb to become the noun I like that you
tighten it up good so now it's now such
a system looks I want to make it we got
a couple minutes left I want to make it
personal to me I'm gonna be selfish so
you have you have a bunch of characters
and I identify most with the Stryver
okay so so just for the audience what is
the Stryver and and then how should I be
I mean I
can sort of be myself a creative person
but there's always other levels of where
to go next what holds a striver back
I've categorized just a bunch of what I
call personas that we all can fall into
there's you know there's the Stryver
there's the the stuck creative there's
the prioritize err like the prioritize
would be oh there's always something
more important than my creativity
there's bills to pay I got to pay to get
or I got a you know get the kids up just
they are unable to recognize the work
that they do and that it matters and you
can't actually go from a 1 to 10 you
don't have to see all of the steps you
just have to see the next four and you
have to walk those so there may be a gap
and this is what I find with everyone
there may be a gap Evon between where
you are right now and where you want to
be and it goes back to that point I made
earlier you don't need a map man you
just need your compass and you have to
just keep walking in that direction so
you know that's a little insight there's
a handful of other tips in the book and
I just found that part to be you know
again this comes not just I didn't just
make this stuff up this is
deconstructing my own life and the lives
of the world's top performers you know
Richard Branson's a mentor and he's an
investor and creativeLIVE Tim Ferriss
Bernie brown people that I've mentioned
this is how they think which of the
personalities do you most self identify
with driver
we're both divers I know we're cutting
short on time and and your Internet's
kind of coming in and out to you but the
book everybody called creative Colleen
chase where do you want people to go
next where am i pre-order in this is a
critical calm Amazon what am i doing is
the next step
sure everywhere books are sold online
and if you if you pre-order there's a
bunch of really cool bonuses at creative
calling calm for example there's a
creative life or doing a class just for
people who own the book so you go there
and upload your receipt there's a
private Q&A for people that are it's
just a small group or you can have your
questions answered sort of one at a time
by me and in that class that I mentioned
it creativeLIVE we're gonna have some
very special guests that I will not I
will not divulge but again anywhere
books are sold
and then go to creative calling comm and
you can get all kinds of
there but you got to do that page tap
you got to do that that expires on on
Tuesday so if you order it now it'll be
in your hands on Tuesday and you can
join the class and if you want to buy
the book for a teacher it's also
creative calling comm yeah it would be
amazing I just announced this on TV
yesterday in Seattle and we just had a
flood of people donating books so we are
if look at 3200 people we are four
thirty seconds of the way there are 1/8
of the way there now so I expect by the
end of next week we might be able to
reach it if people like you at home
listening just donate one or two or five
books I will personally pay to fulfill
these books I will dropship there's a
hundred and thirteen schools in the
Seattle Public School District I'm
paying to get these books to these
teachers and you just have to donate the
book and I'll take care of the rest
and then I believe this is a great
experiment that we'll be able to
replicate in other cities I love it I
love it so much and so for YouTube we
will link that up in the description
below so you can go check it out as well
chase man appreciate the time safe
flight home man
much respect thank you for having me on
the show Evan I really appreciate it
awesome
take care man bye bye if you want more
Chase Jarvis trigger the top ten rules I
did on him the link is right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and I'll see you there